hey guys it is the very best day in the
working week and I've got the best
gaming news from the last week all ready
to go for you so let's get into that
[Music]
father hasn't gonna give the war game on
PC for 10 years that's all changing with
gears of war for the developer have said
the controls are balanced on gamepad
first but they're also paying attention
to keyboard and mouse on PC you'll be
able to choose between using a keyboard
and mouse or a controller lead
multiplayer designer ryan cleveland told
IGN the core of the game is around a
controller I don't think we'd say that
we have like one of the other as the
priority but we have to make sure that
the controller experience which has been
the legacy of the game is definitely
perfect up until this point the series
has been Xbox exclusive with only the
first game and its ultimate edition
coming to PC Cleavon went on to say Vic
use of force multiplayer on PC and Xbox
are balanced independently and when
you're playing competitively online you
won't be facing off against players on
the other platform anyway Gears of War
for is out on October 11 for both xbox
one and pc this story is going to sound
like it's coming out of a different
decade but it seems a lot of you guys
are still playing solitaire that's right
windows solitaire the newest edition
Microsoft solitaire collection for
windows 8 and stan has hit more than 100
million unique users and an average of
55 million games of the collection are
played every day that's a lot of people
procrastinating until the clock hits 5
the collections coming to iOS and
Android devices this fall to distract
you further and there are a bunch of
awards to be one in a new upcoming game
mode called events the collection
includes five different types of the
classic card game including spider
pyramid and freecell onto something a
tad more action-packed three assassins
creed ezio collection appears to be on
the way the game appeared on the Korean
ratings board earlier this month and
it's now been detailed on the French
publication game blog promotional
materials were posted as well as the
news that the collection will feature a
1080p resolution and will run at 30
frames per second it will include
assassin's creed two Assassin's Creed
Brotherhood and assassin's creed
revelations as well as all respective
DLC and the short films
creed lineage and assassin's creed
Ender's Game blog suggests the
collection will come to ps4 and Xbox one
in November for 70 euro next up you
could be speeding around town in
cyberpunk 2077 when it launches sometime
in the next one to five years said
approach red have been posting dozens of
job listings for the cyberpunk team and
a few of those cluing us into what to
expect from the game two of these
listings call for a vehicle gameplay
designer and a vehicle gameplay
programmer the duties described of the
roles include creating vehicle based
gameplay including handling controls and
combat as well as coding the
contraptions and creating the physics of
driving and flying in said vehicles that
approach dread have said they'll talk
more about the game when they have
something to show so don't hold your
breath finally the battlefield 1 beta
launched this week and it worked and it
didn't and then it worked again and
here's a bit more info on that a whole
lot of plays were experiencing issues
when the game rolled out to everyone
earlier this week it then became
apparent that a whole bunch of EA games
were having server issues not just
battlefield one and the EA support
Twitter account so they were
experiencing an outage the issues
appeared to have been largely resolved
on Thursday well there's been no
official word on what exactly happened
there was some speculation that hackers
were involved a group of whom did take
responsibility in any case you should be
able to play battlefield one spacer in
peace for the moment this week on site
we tell you about all the sweet things
you can do in battlefield one chat about
what's new in world of warcraft
allegiant and check out fallout 4 nikka
world that is everything I happy this
week do let me know what you cared about
and what you'll be playing this weekend
and I will see you again on Monday
[Music]